hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jesse this is Jesse and today we're
going to work on routing and maybe bring
it over some data and we're going to
start out with figuring out a solution
to a feature that I know that we've
needed for a long time I've just kind of
been doing other things so for you you
know why not try it today I have an idea
of how to make it work but I haven't
tested it yet so we'll work on that
together I'd like to get at least one
Pomodoro session in today and then maybe
maybe another one or maybe we'll just go
right to questions it depends on whether
or not we figure this out so I already
put in for Pomodoro sessions of just
data migration so my brain is ready to
switch it up a little bit and and work
on this so let me wait there we are at
the wait a second for the analytics data
to update it was showing I had zero
viewers Jenna wasn't true because some
of you were waiting before the stream
even started all right just a heads up
to everybody I'll probably remind you
again at the end but I will not be
streaming tomorrow I will be at the
Google i/o extension conference in
Pittsburgh so if anybody's around the
Pittsburgh area and will be there let me
let me know let's see oh it was when you
switch over as you can see this screen
will get started when the start my
Pomodoro clock I'll just explain to you
very quickly what we're trying to
accomplish and and then we'll get to it
if you all have any ideas on how to make
this happen please let me know but I'll
say what we're going to do then I'll
explain to you with my ideas and then
we'll get to coding so this pay
this faculty page the uro is education
slash faculty so when we have slash
education as the URL that takes us to
our it displays what's under the post
type of majors but on this particular
page we don't want to hard-code this
list what we want to do since we already
have a post site for faculty members and
you can see well you can't see it's too
small but when you go to a faculty
member page the URL is slash faculty
slash and then the faculty members name
so totally different post type but we
have the category of the the program so
what we should be able to do is say
something like if if you go to this page
to a faculty page within a certain
program a certain major then grab also
grab the the data from the the faculty
post type but only those pieces of data
that have the category that matches the
the program here from the URL in this
case education so it'll be a little bit
different than what we're used to and
we'll definitely have to we'll have to
iterate over that data so we're going to
map over that data so first steps first
is let's get a route into the router so
we have something to look at on a page
and then we'll get to the rest of it
okay so here's our router and let's make
sure we we have the English route let's
just
all right cool so we do have English so
if we have English / classes it goes to
here we have senior thesis in your
portfolio so let's go here and add
faculty as a route and if we're going to
add faculty then we'll pass in the slub
or I'm sorry we'll pass in the ID hmm
maybe here if the routers faculty will
pass in maybe English let's try this so
if if we have the rout of faculty will
pass in English but here's what I'm
gonna try to do I'm going to add in some
extra stuff here and I'm gonna see if
our router can handle that so let me
type it out and then I'll go back and
explain what I'm what I'm doing
default type is going
goody lists
okay alright so I'm gonna say that I
don't think it'll work right away we're
gonna have to do some more work on our
router but here's here's what I've done
here's what I hope will will happen at
some point
hey everyone I see a few you saying hi
in the chat so welcome hey Ana John
Matthew and Harsha
Oh Harshit that's great hard [ __ ] and I
have been working on a side project as
well as Nikki's been working on it and
JavaScript err I should say I've been
doing not that much work at all ours
just been doing Harshit and the others
have been doing all the work but just
wanted to say hi and that that's
actually going to come out today the
beta version so maybe Harsha can let you
know the URL in the chat if it's if it's
ready soon all right so here's what I
think is gonna happen what I hope will
happen is so we have when someone goes
to the route English what will happen is
by default we'll do the same thing as we
normally do is that we're going to go to
the the page the components of major and
the default post type to get the data
from is going to be majors and then the
ID which is that last part of the URL by
default would just be English to display
the home page for the English department
but then depending on what goes in here
it may display something else but if we
get faculty instead of you know anything
else as that last part of the URL
I wanted to display a component that
we're gonna create called faculty list
and I wanted to use the post type
faculty because that's we're going to
get the data from then I wanted to pass
in as an ID to graph QL English so that
we can use that
to grab the category English and have
those particular post types show up so
there are a few things that might need
to change I don't know if we can select
categories by slug or we need to use an
ID not onshore so you may have to switch
this to the ID number for English also I
don't know if we built this
functionality into the router yet to
handle all of this I know it works for
the IDS but I don't know if it works for
pages and types so first things first I
guess we'll just navigate to it and see
what kind of errors we get so first
let's make sure I didn't mess up the
normal routes so we're gonna go straight
to English and see if anything happens
okay I did not mess up these are outs
just awesome and I want to make sure
let's see English classes see if this
route works tell you the truth I'm not
sure if this shot ever works because I
don't know if I set up the data for it
I'm guessing it's not going to work this
nothing's happening alright let's look
at another SUV try something on senior
thesis alright enough with that let's
just go to the faculty see if we we're
gonna get an error I just want to see
what the error is did I mess this up a
lot
I'm just gonna restart that server
actually I don't know if I ever did to
get pool to start things out
no I
let's just stash these for now
yeah always start out your day with the
get pool so otherwise who have weird
stuff happens so how do i unstack
something now I'm gonna have to look
this up if anybody knows how to unstack
would I just stash offhand let me know
in the live chat now otherwise I'm gonna
look it up
you just forget stash pop or once our
changes okay
sweet
all right good stash pop so I did look
it up and I see Vishal you you put that
in the chat you probably would add it in
faster if it wasn't for the delay in the
in the stream itself so thank you
thank you for that I never needed to
unsay anything before
that's crazy I've known this for years
I've never actually had to understand
something that's one of the cool things
I think about doing this kind of work
you learn new stuff constantly okay and
I'm not sure if there any questions you
have in the chat but just to let you
know in case this is your first time
watching I will get to the questions in
the chat I'm just gonna do a bit of code
first and then I'll get to the chat
later on so if you can just hang in
there for a little bit your question
will get answered hopefully I can answer
it alright so now that we have the
changes in here where they should be
let's go back over here and see this
site cannot be reached
oh because I restarted it let's see if
we can get this to load enough to give
us some sort of error message otherwise
I guess we can just start making our
component you know I should be able to
go down to the the routing function and
just see if this would even work so
let's let me just stop that for now
let's go down to our routing function
and walk through step by step what will
happen if we give the routing function
this this data all right so what I'm
gonna do is I'm actually going to wait
is this I may already have this open in
both places No
you know
keep I just I just want to open it up in
two places it's all I want to do so once
you all be able to see what we have at
the top versus what we have at the
bottom of this game this page see if
it'll let me all right cool so now we
have the same file open in both sides
let's shrink this down we don't need it
and what I'd like to do is I'm gonna
leave this here so we can see exactly
what data where we're passing into our
routing function and we're gonna scroll
down here to the routing function and
step through what will happen with this
data and that way even though we're not
getting an error message to help us we
should be able to catch the errors and
adjust the the routing function like
that so I'm gonna do my best to try to
explain this as I go along
if you if you'd like to look at this on
your own computer check out the link to
the repository it's in the description
to this video or on the server J s file
on the master branch okay so here's what
happens when the browser would navigate
to that slash English slash faculty
route so it's gonna look at this first
one is going to be slash English the
second will be faculty we will have no
third right so that first program
English second purim faculty alright
let's continue on all this we don't need
to worry about
so the type is going to be first trim
the page equal page type first frame
pages okay so this is not really going
to be an issue because we're telling it
what the type is so this is like kind of
a default back up if we don't say that
so we can keep on going through here so
if the length of the params are one it's
going to do this we can skip that
because we have to write English and
faculty so let's go all the way down to
here and we're gonna go to this else if
alright and this is what we want where
it's there's two parts to the URL
okay so we're logging these defaults so
if I didn't include the page in the type
by default it would just go to the
component called page and render that
component and then it would use the post
type which is whatever the first
parameter is in this case it would be
English it would say English pages that
post type doesn't exist but it doesn't
matter that's why we're explicitly
saying what the post type is that we
want here so we're gonna look now if the
first parameter is found in our
translation object so our translation
object is this huge object we can't even
see all of it but we would find the
first parameter here English okay so
then if English dot page exists which it
does we're gonna go in here and let's
see if this equals an object which it
does then we're gonna say page equals
translation object first ram-paige
standard
okay we need we need to change it so
this is where the the air is gonna occur
we don't have standard okay so what
would normally happen is is we would put
default as one key and then standard as
the other key and then we would tell it
but that's not going to work for us
because if I were to type in English /
senior thesis that won't work for what
trying to do here with our faculty or
faculty list component here so we need
to adjust this to check to see if
standard is there allister's the first
program equals type so what will then
happen
oops stunner position first rampage so
the else here is if it's not an object
so what needs to happen is if it is an
object we're going to look to standard
will then have to be the fallback
default yeah this I'm going to adjust
this function in a way so that we can
use custom values for page but if there
isn't a custom value that matches then
then we'll use standard okay all right
so that's what we'll do then so in this
case we're passing in let's see what
page okay so I D so here's what we need
to do so we're going to say if
translation our text Rampage dots pay
page anything
so if this exists right if translation
object first for am dot page and then ID
which would be the second parameter
which in this case is faculty if that
exists as a key in this object which it
does in this case then we're going to
want to set page equal to this
translation object first Rampage ID okay
so which in this case page would get set
to faculty list which is what we want
we're gonna add an else in here and
let's move this up a line just to clean
it up so it'll try to find that ID if
for some reason this ID isn't explicitly
set here it will try to fall back and
use standard let me think if that'll be
enough no that won't be enough it won't
be enough okay so we don't want we need
another fall but the other fall back
this is getting a mess but we need
another if statement here because we're
not actually going to add a standard end
so what happens if somebody puts in
slash English / senior thesis it's going
to go through it's going to get to this
point it's going to say okay that ID
doesn't exist so let's just use page dot
standard well page now standard doesn't
exist either but we're not checking for
that we're just assuming it exists so
that's going to give us an error so we
need to do first is check to see if this
exists and that that needs to be an else
if
so else if this then our page can be set
to standard and then we need to add one
more else else we're just gonna go for
the default so page is just going to
equal defaults whoa okay let's save that
let me check my time okay about two
minutes that's not bad because then
that'll give me some time to answer
questions in case anyone's confused and
then the next step will be which we
probably won't get through the next step
so I'm just gonna tell you what it's
going to be we need to find the type so
first thing that's gonna happen if the
type exists as a parameter which it does
and if it is the object which it is then
we're going to go for this standard
write our standard does not exist so
basically what we're gonna have to do
right now is the same thing we did up
here and we're just going to replace
type we're going to replace page with
type so we can copy and paste this so
let's go with from here down to here
you should be able to do this right okay
and then in here oops yeah let's replace
every instance of page with type
typ e
I mean tape
okay and then with ID
okay I think ideal or actually work so
my timer is up but we we may be at a
point where we could at least get an
error hey yes we got some type of error
let's see if we got more info no see fit
more info here nothing
No
one more refresh
404 okay we'll come back to this and I'm
gonna scroll up I'm gonna set a
five-minute timer now I answer some
questions and then we'll do another
25-minute Pomodoro session
alright time to find a lot of hellos I'm
trying to find a question here
I'm scrolling down I'm almost to the
bottom and there are no questions yet
I'll just to losen you all talking to
each other which i think is awesome here
we go John Hanson says would async
promises work cleaner than all of those
if statements yet honestly there's got
to be there's got to be a better way to
do this I know when we first did this
and I believe it was Nikki that did a
lot of the original work it was a much
smaller function I've added a lot more
to this as I came across different parts
of the site the old site that I needed
to bring over and make sure the URLs
work so what we originally thought would
work didn't work for every use case so
we just kind of added this stuff on I'm
definitely open to refactoring at this
point like if this is working the way
we're doing it I got to go with it for
now because we're gonna launch in less
than a month so I can't I just don't
think I have enough time to refactor
this and make it work and make sure it
works in all our use cases but I think
it's a worthwhile thing to do at some
point because this is getting quite
large there are a ton of nested if
statements so at the very least it's
just a mess to read and think through
I mean I'm able to think through it
right now but I've seen it it's a lot so
yeah it's not ideal nikki says yeah I
feel a shame when I see that code it
made sense at the time but boy does that
look messy well Nikki it's not your
fault like I just said like a lot of the
mess is things that I've had to add in
so I think the original when I saw the
original function Nikki I have my
immediate thought was Nikki as a genius
like this is amazing this works but then
as I dug through the data on the site
and the content I realize like oh this
one
work for everything which has it's not
your fault at all based on the
information I gave you it worked
perfectly but I just didn't have
complete information at that time
Michael was volunteered to make the
chain refactoring changes and he says I
would but I think Jesse wants to site to
work hey if anybody wants to tackle
refactoring feel free to fork the repo
make a branch and try it out you know it
it won't break the main site you know of
course and if I were to try to redo this
I would most definitely do it on a
separate branch I'm not I'm not even
gonna attempt to untangle this this mass
of if statements on the the master
branch here all cool Phoenix is here it
says sorry late I was doing my 30 days
30 sites challenge submission that's
awesome so you're still keeping up with
that that's that's amazing doing 30
sites in 30 days so I did I just think
that's awesome
so keep me up to date on on the stuff
you're you're putting out there I'd love
to check it out Matthew says thanks for
doing these live streams Jesse learned a
lot from watching your workflow oh
you're welcome thank you for saying that
hey Frankie's here nice to see you here
Frankie all right I think my timer is
beeping yep let's start another Pomodoro
session and let's give this to work okay
let's look at where we potentially could
have some problems one is that this
faculty list thing it doesn't it doesn't
exist so let's make this and then we'll
go from there the best thing probably be
you cloning existing component and then
adapt it I think we can get things done
more quickly like that
so I was hoping I'd have a good one
already opening but I don't all right so
let's just go in here to our pages and
oops that was CSS I just stopped because
it had the right names there we are so
the faculty dot J s component is
probably going to be the closest to what
we're actually going to use no will it
yeah you know it it might
okay and it is using the new a new way
to do it alright let's grab this we're
gonna copy this we're gonna make a new
page called
what was it I don't remember what we
call the new page faculty list a new
page
alright faculty list a s let's change
what we need to looks good
faculty lists we're done here
faculty list and pass the ID
we're gonna have to make a separate
query for this because it's gonna be a
little different than what we normally
have yeah at least we can save that
let's just refresh see if we get
anything different not expecting it but
oh nice we got an error message happy
about that alright cool so this is great
news
it may not look like great news but this
is really great news so if you can see
let's see Phil let me zoom in so check
that out so it says cannot read property
note of undefined and it's giving us
this error from faculty list J s line 34
that means that our router worked and it
directed the user directed the flow of
our data I guess to that faculty list
component not only that but it seems
that something came through for ID and
we're getting because it's actually like
attempting to make that that graph QL
query right so that error tells us that
I think we did what we're supposed to do
now what we need to do is adjust our
query to get the data that we need from
this alright so here's what we need the
type is correct we can leave it as is
because it's going to go to the faculty
post site the ID needs to change though
so what query are we using we're using
profile query
we need a different one we need a guess
we'll make a faculty list query let's
check out our queries I'm going to see
if there's one that would work I don't
know that we've used any queries yet
that return exactly what we need so
let's just look first at this profile or
separate there you get profile okay
let's move it over here so we can look
at both at the same time all right so
what we're searching for now is so our
type is here and that's that's fine that
doesn't need to change but where we're
saying name we're looking for name name
so that's that ID and the name ends up
being our slug or our WordPress slug we
don't care about that what we want is we
want to search by category by faculty
departments
I wonder
hold on I don't want to do it to this
one I don't think that's gonna work I'm
just kind of trying it now because if it
does end up working it'll save us it's
on a time I don't really have hopes for
that I think we're gonna have to look up
exactly how to do this with WP graph QL
which is the plugin that we're using I
need to make a new query and we'll call
this faculty lists okay
so let's just refresh the page see what
we're getting No
we could use
let's see I change this to
is that not it what's my wordpress you
are WP Franciscan da University yeah
that's it let's try to bring our query
over
all right we don't we don't actually
need all that let's go from here
the type is gonna be faculty
okay
let's just start from
or on faculty
yeah let's look
let me look over at the live chat to see
if anybody is giving any suggestions
okay suggestions let's
let's just look up the documentation
okay
i D
I'm not getting exactly the same thing
so what I want to see is in this case I
guess we can do we're doing education
we can pass this as a stream
sorry I thought that's what it just said
I could do right
we're friends I was absolutely
okay I need to put the variable in there
all right that makes sense where am I
category
all right I don't know what I'm doing
let's take this I'll need that
faculty where I wanted to be named
faculty departments
departments all equals
you'll need this right now right
do you need that but what's wrong with
this
alright check this out again
alright Michael says shouldn't ID be
faculty department ID ID is a graph QL
ID
I'm not sure okay the truth and I don't
know why I'm not getting
like what I should I should be able to
get some schema stuff about area let me
see
faculty
you see see if there's any more data on
this part of it list the pose let's
suppose we'll offer info users
advanced there's nothing for advanced
queries know how these topics all right
all right let me look Michael says
underneath faculty departments okay let
me let me look back here yeah so under
faculty departments oh you know what
yeah if I was gonna do it like that I
would need to put let me go back here
faculty departments I don't need name
like that I need faculty departments
edges note the name
let's even get anything from that no
let's let me just copy this over so I
think I've thoroughly messed up what I
was trying to do over over here let me
just
it just happened I
okay it does not like that
are we working with originally
michael says why don't you try hard
coding the variable into the query yeah
actually let me alright so we oh we are
actually getting some stuff in here
let's try
there we go
maybe we could use category name but
it's it's a custom taxonomy I mean let's
this tribe
and ago her name is gonna education
double gotta use double quotes okay name
variable never use yeah
do I need this
it's been so long since I made graph QL
queries I don't remember this the right
syntax for this do I even need this
there we go
all right let's see okay to return
nothing
I don't think I can do
and then feel
I can do a search but I have a feeling
the word education is going to be in all
of these
my timer went off so let me take a
little break whoops a short break and
answer some questions I have one more
idea
[Applause]
it's
so it looks like
oh I should ask have you found any bugs
or need some feature on pom pom I just
never looked at it in six months no I
mean it's it's working great so I don't
know what I would what I would need
I yeah the only thing I would say on
there is the the beeping beeping can get
a little annoying like it's just a long
and amount of beeping it's good because
I never missed the beep but if I like
hear the beep right away and I'm like
okay it's beeping and it just keeps
beeping and beeping and beeping so I
don't know maybe like a warning beep and
then some silence and then the ending
beep instead of like constant beeps
other than that do I really like it and
I in case you're wondering pom-pom is
this Pomodoro timer that are should
build that so it's really cool I'm a
Spotify quickly
okay
some some comments got hidden so I just
unhidden get hidden before it's it's up
now Phoenix says I just wanted to ask
when looking for a remote job what
documents are mandatory to be submitted
like if I work remotely for a company in
the US what documents do I need you know
what I'm not entirely sure I don't know
what's what's required like if you were
to actually come here and work in the
United States that we require a
documentation I don't really know if
you're doing remote work I don't know
because it I guess it depends to like if
you're gonna be a full-time remote
employee for a company there's probably
gonna be some tax documents and things
that need to be set up if you're like a
freelancer doing remote work for a
company then that that probably is a
little bit easier
all right Michael has put in a query
let's try this I'm gonna copy and paste
this and we're shot we're gonna try it
this is cool this is like a totally
reverse way of doing it but if it works
this is gonna be awesome I just wouldn't
have thought of that at all
No okay let's try to it's missing less
Curly's yeah I was just saying let's
let's try to separate this out so we get
what we need here so let me start up
another Pomodoro's hammer
I don't slug
as a one two three four five six seven
one two three four five six seven
whoa Michael ah Michael thank you so
much I'm so happy I'm sorry this is
awesome
let me enjoy it for a second and then
I'll try to explain what's going on this
is really cool so cool all right
so Michael has figured this out and
here's what's happening instead of
searching for faculty and then trying to
somehow sort by faculty departments
which there was no option to do that it
wasn't let me do this so Michael has the
idea like okay why not try to find
faculty departments where the name
equals education which makes complete
sense that's that we should be able to
find those and then faculty you can get
back to the faculty through that which I
I never even thought was possible
that's amazing amazing that's that's
awesome so let's let's make sure okay
yeah so we all we need then is the name
and the title and I guess the [ __ ] we
need the slug to be able to construct
the URL so what are we getting now so
title a slug shoot how are you gonna get
this
we don't have that yet when we brought
the data over that was contained in the
content that's one big block so that
data is not gonna be available and so we
can make a custom field and put it in
the custom field which is something I
was planning on doing anyway
that may be something needs to get done
sooner than I anticipated
okay all right but this works so let's
take this move it over here
let's see you know what am I gonna pass
to type-in I really don't need to pass
the type-in we're not gonna reuse this
query at least not now not right now so
I think we're fine I just hope it
doesn't give us an error because we're
bringing in type and not using it and
let's change this name faculty this
query let's save that let's go over here
and we're gonna use oh you know what no
wonder and even none of my tests earlier
worked I never connected this to the
component so I mean not that they
would've worked anyway cuz I didn't get
it right but I really didn't get it
right so this query is called
faculty list and this is actually let's
find this elsewhere faculty this query
save it
alright now let's see what we're getting
there we go
I can't read edges of undefined so this
makes sense because we're going to need
to redo all of this how we're getting
this data so we don't need all this kind
of stuff here
it's annotate uh-oh
we can leave it for now we're just we
don't really need it so we don't want
content what we want then in the div
when a map over I you know what if we
take our search page we should be able
to copy and paste some things that'll be
helpful to us so let's check out our
search page whoops
search yes because we're getting data
here that's you know what we weren't
using graph QL for this so it may not be
as helpful as I thought yeah it won't be
shoot okay that's all right we can see
what data we're getting from here so the
data will be in this format so we can
just use this to figure out how we're
gonna do things Oh Nikki reminded me
delete that global X yeah who is that
there we go
all right so
we're not even getting content really so
yeah let's get rid of this
we don't want content what we want is
node what are we getting faculty node
faculty edges all right so we're gonna
say we're gonna call this faculty data
and then down here let's just start with
what we're gonna do here so we're gonna
say we're gonna have a container div and
then within that let's map
so faculty data map and I'm gonna say
data whoops
it's a faculty
and then within here let's just from
right now do an h3 and we'll put in
what's it called title yeah let's just
put in title age three is going to be
faculty dot title okay and then here am
I gonna have any problems with this
I don't think I'll need to set this
dangerous ESET innerhtml for the title I
think we should be fine what is all this
Oh indentation I fine then what is this
key prop okay
key is gonna equal fact what he slug cuz
that'll be unique now let's try this
factory this you're gonna map over see
what we get here
no what happened edges can I read edges
oh did I mess it up and not account for
the edges and the faculty no I didn't I
didn't account for no though so we got
node faculty edges and then never again
let's see oh I know
so it needs to be our query is putting
in the type faculty lists or something
yeah what do we wanna get one on you
we're passing in faculty that's not what
we want we want data faculty departments
faculty departments
let's try that I'm getting a bunch of
messages on my phone
let me check to make sure it's not work
our [ __ ]
versus sending me messages on Twitter at
the same time
okay let's see we have now oh nice we
didn't get an air right away each shot
HFD keep Rob and the method of query
oh I know what else I messed up faculty
they they were awesome why are we still
getting needing this iterator thing I
thought we had a keeper up key
yeah the h3 has a key why
all right I'm not worried about that
right now I'll figure that out but all
right cool so we got the data displayed
on the page still need but we need to do
work on the data itself in WordPress to
get the data though that we need so like
you notice we don't have a picture we
don't have the title we don't have a
link we can actually make the the link
to their page we have enough data for
that but those are things that are going
to be really boring that need to happen
in WordPress and it's just going to be a
lot of I create the custom fields and
then a lot of copy and paste work
hopefully I can maybe get a student
worker it's do that so that I can keep
working on on other things but actually
not not too bad this is
mission accomplished thanks to Michael
just thank you again let me yeah I'm
gonna end this or I have 10 minutes left
in this appointment or session but I'm
just gonna end it and go to the chat now
and let me I mean look
all right so I found where I left off in
the chat if you have any questions
please let me know now and as soon as I
get to the bottom of the chat and I'm
gonna end the stream oh we have I got a
meeting soon so definitely and the
stream soon and a heart should I got
your messages on Twitter I'm not sure if
you also sent a message in the chat but
I'm giving you access right now on my
other screen I'm not sure why I'm not
sure why I made you an admin so I don't
know why but oh I guess I'll make you
project owner as well okay so now you
should have full access to the the
project since you're the project owner
just don't don't run up a bill on my
credit card and other than that you're
good to do whatever
Oh her she says use prettify button in
the the graph graph QL thing oh yeah so
that would have saved me a minute
wish I would have looked over thanks
Harsha so I manually put all those
there's breaks in oh well glad I learned
it now the
you gotta close out of it Michelson you
got to close that other div I would add
I mess up with
all right I must have closed it then I
don't I don't know what I was doing and
Michael said Michael has got a
scholarship for a nano degree for
Udacity Michael you may have already
told me this but just in case I haven't
done so already
congratulations I'd like to congratulate
you for that okay for the mobile web
specialist cool
it's
all right Rohan Verma says I already did
the machine learning nanodegree the
basic in advance six months long course
Oh awesome
congratulations Roland how was that
course would it would if you had to give
advice on whether the course was worth
it for someone to take what would you
say
well I should ask if I'm gonna run a
wordpress cluster in production or we'll
add more power to the droplet what I'd
like to do is maybe run a cluster if I
don't have time I will just add more
power to the droplet I've been looking
into actually taking the database and
hosting that like on AWS or Google or
something on one of their managed
database services to just kind of take
that they'll handle backups and scaling
and things like that and I won't have to
worry about it
and then still I would have to host
WordPress on a droplet or something so
that's my plan and in which case if I do
that I still wanted to I would like it
to be on multiple droplets because there
is going to be a lot of traffic
Rowen says is no js' suitable for HPC I
don't know what HPC is if you let me
know what that stands for maybe I can
answer michael says yes he had an issue
on what info you need so I can take a
look you know what Michael it's not the
the info isn't even there so that's the
problem is that we we can't get it from
graph QL because it doesn't exist so the
data needs to be entered into WordPress
first like even the the fields itself
don't even exist
okay her [ __ ] has done what he needed to
do and I can he doesn't need to be
project owner anymore so I'll drop you
back down Harsha just let me know if you
need it again
it's not really a big deal I trust you
all right Rowland says I would say
machine learning nano degree program for
Udacity is awesome for those who are
migrating from some other field to
machine learning but course from
Coursera deep learning ai specialization
is better than Udacity okay that's good
to know because I've considered knowing
the Udacity course but it's it's
definitely not it doesn't have anything
to do with what I'm working with right
now so it probably wouldn't help me that
much my day-to-day work it would be a
big commitment the money and time so
maybe I don't know maybe I'll check out
that other course and see if that's
would be less of a time commitment I see
how it's set up
okay Roland says high-performance
computing is what HP use talking about
with HPC until the true sigh I don't
really know I don't have enough
knowledge about that to say one way or
another so apologies on that if anybody
else has a better insight than I do into
that please let Rohan know in the chat
and you know what I yeah I had a meeting
coming up soon and I've gone through
everything in the chat so tomorrow I
will not be streaming I will be at the
Google i/o extension conference in
Pittsburgh so please let me know if
you're gonna be in Pittsburgh especially
if you're gonna be at the conference I'd
love to be able to say hello in real
life and also please check out JSA F so
that's a website that I've been working
on with with a few other with Harshit
with Nikki with JavaScript errors in
there sometimes in the live chat and
it's just a place where you can share
your github repos share a little bit of
info with that it can help you search
for other people's repos I think in
potentially a better way than you can on
github totally built with a lot of the
technologies that we've been working
with here it's open source you can check
out you know the project on github and
contribute but definitely check it out
Harshit let me see I don't know if it's
a down or up now our shit's working on
it but maybe oh um I'm gonna paste the
link in here I pasted the link in there
now you may have to copy and paste that
sometimes links are weird in the YouTube
chat are we using the beta JavaScript on
AF er we're using just straight-up
JavaScript out AFR [ __ ]
all right it looks like all right yeah
JavaScript af redirects anyway oh there
yeah so you can you don't have to add in
the beta it redirects if you just use
JavaScript AF but anyway please check it
out if you find some weird stuff going
on or if you have ideas for it open up
an issue on github and let us know like
I said we'd love to have a lot of ideas
and contributors we think this could be
a cool resource for the community and
and and we're not we like we don't have
funding we're just doing this as a side
project right now you know we haven't
been gettin paid ours just been doing a
ton of work I've been paying for domain
and servers and everything so yeah so
any help that you could give would be
would be awesome
and I don't mean like just financially I
mean like in terms of your ideas
you know advice pool requests things
like that so anyway I will probably be
streaming on Wednesday and I'm gonna try
to maybe do some updates on Instagram
from the Google i/o conference I don't
know if I'll be able to get any updates
on YouTube but if I do they won't be on
the free code Kent channel they'll be on
my own YouTube channel so the links of
my youtube channel is in the description
you can also I think find a link to my
Instagram on my youtube channel so if I
happen to be able to do any updates on
on YouTube or Instagram if you follow me
or subscribe then you'll probably get
notified let's see I think that's it so
I'll see y'all wednesday have a great
day today and and tomorrow and let's see
sorry I couldn't find the button to
leaves try to do my usual outro and then
I couldn't find the button I was on the
wrong page alright anyway thank you all
so much and I'll see you on Wednesday